this morning on the dish award-winning
chef Andy husbands growing up in Seattle
in Massachusetts he started his career
at age 14 with a job at a bakery after
culinary school he worked at top
kitchens across the country before
returning to the Bay State in 1996 he
opened his own restaurant
Tremont six for seven and just last year
the smoke shop featuring his
award-winning barbecue his crew was the
first northeastern team ever to win the
Jack Daniel's World Championship and his
fifth cookbook pitmaster came out just
this month chef Andy husbands good
morning welcome to the dish good morning
chef so would you bring us watch a whole
lot of stuff yeah I see yeah I see that
some half sour pickles over there
pickle jalapenos like cornbread which we
serve with honey sea salt butter amazing
this is the piece de resistance of
course this is our brisket we smoked
this this was about an 18 pound piece
and we smoked it for about an hour a
pound so about probably 16 18 hours in
cherry all of our wood comes out of New
Hampshire gold sauce which I do suggest
you try with the brisket South Carolina
barbecue sauce I love it with anything
pretty much macaroni cheese collards and
then this fun guy which is a caramel
cake Wow better and better and better so
you are new england-based yes but here
we have known for barbecue yeah how did
that all happen
well I've been a study of studying
barbecue for I would say 20 25 years now
it's something that I've been involved
with and I love the history and
passionate about it and we just really
dug deep and tried to start competing in
barbecue and I just learned a lot of
lessons and learned how to get kind of
good at it well you have brisket here
and I know from painful personal
experience that brisket is not easy to
make it can either be gelatinous or it
can be tough as a boot right right it's
a it's a lot of practice you know in our
in our book pitmaster we we have a bunch
of guest pitmasters who kind of give you
tips on how to do things as well as we
give you tips of course and I wrote it
with my best friend Chris Hart who is
just an amazing pitmaster you know
briskets is it's what's what's great
about barbecue in general is its
practice yeah
and I guarantee you make these recipes
are gonna come out
great and then I guarantee after the
20th time you make it's gonna be even
better better when you talk about your
when one talks about your career in
cooking you start it out I mean you had
a job in a bakery yeah I read something
about a doughnut challenge early on when
you were younger
tell us about your progression to to
risk it
you know I cooking has been something
that's I've just always loved it and
when I was in fourth grade I made I had
this kind of little competition on how
to make doughnuts and that's what I did
kind of wonder where my parents were
self directed competition
it was know is in school we were doing
kind of a how-to thing and we that was
the thing that I entered you know and I
just cooking is about passion if you
really really enjoy it and really enjoy
anything you're gonna get good at it and
I'm very passionate about barbecue and I
love the history and you know I would
put forth it's America's true cuisine
how did your your previous I mean your
award-winning restaurant Tremont 647 how
did that the knowledge that you gained
there dovetail with what you're doing
now
well I mean restaurants are really about
hospitality and and knowing what the
customer wants yeah so for us when we
went to open up the smoke shop in
Kendall Square you know we really wanted
to focus on making sure everybody gets
what they want and we're doing it right
well I'm getting what I want especially
with the caramel cake at the end chef as
I asked you to sign this dish as is
customary on this show I want to pose
the question we post every visiting chef
which is if you could share this meal
with any figure past or present who
would it be
I was the share of this meal you know I
would say my family I think barbecue is
about celebration and family and that's
really what to me so my past and my
present family
I think this brisket would feed them all
absolutely right it's terrific chef Andy
husbands thanks so much and for more on
Andy husband's and the dish head to our
website at CBS this morning dot-com